un million parmi les 40 millions de
masques distribués à des personnes en
situation de précarité
le ministre des solidarités de la santé
olivier ferrand a mandaté le groupe la
poste pour s'occuper de la distribution
il a fait le point sur l'organisation de
la logistique sur des sites yvelinois il
ne doit pas il ne saurait y avoir le
moindre obstacle financier pour que les
français puissent se protéger et ainsi
ce sont 8 millions de français notamment
ceux qui bénéficient de ce qu'on appelle
la complémentaire santé solidaire qui
vont recevoir et qui ont commencé à
recevoir et qui recevront pendant les 10
à 15 prochains jours
des masques grand public et c'est ainsi
une action de solidarité je suis
ministre de la santé mais aussi ministre
des solidarités cette plateforme
logistique du groupe la poste située à
buc est mobilisé dans la mise sous pli
des masques trente-huit personnes ont
été recrutées pour cette mission sur ce
site vous attendez plus tendu par leurs
mentors place jusqu'au 11 août
sur des horaires de 14 heures jour il ya
un ensemble de jeunes qui sont sur cette
tâche de fabrication des flux et donc de
des enveloppes ce que nous allons voir
ici c'est ces enveloppes une fois collé
rentrer dans le circuit de distribution
des facteurs donc on va voir comment les
facteurs prennent ces enveloppes pour
les distribuer à la population
la plateforme de distribution du
courrier de montigny le bretonneux va
s'occuper de l'envoi de 1600 masque sur
la commune une activité quasi habituel
pour les 210 facteurs de ce centre saint
quentinois la différence qu'il ya entre
un pli normale et se plaint ce que si on
n'arrive pas à leur entrée dans la boîte
aux lettres parce qu'elle est pas
normalisée on va le livrer directement
aux clients
si le client n'est pas là on avise et il
vient ensuite le chercher au guichet ici
cette opération devrait durer jusqu'au
12 août le temps pour organiser l'envoi
des masques dans toute la france